it's getting it's getting crazy and
crazy right now
and you're a winner by decision
[Music]
welcome to cats after dark uh we're the
usual crew you know us that's here every
week same six same six four six uh yeah
you guys just got back from the
brendan shop show in san diego uh so
you guys room together we did everybody
was down there except christian i know
george woodson yeah you went no yeah
they we actually got an airbnb but i had
my own room
we had a bed that had two beds so we
like all right we might as well have
kyle
yeah come stay with them they're like
well this is gonna be terrible
and it was for them probably no i had a
great time yeah it was good but we're
the worst roommates ever because we're
the type of people that let our alarms
go off and then just silence them yeah
right i would snooze his would go off
two seconds later he would snooze and uh
we we did that for like 45 minutes about
45. see on vacation i can't even sleep
in i'm like uh excited to go out even if
i wanted to i can't this was from like 8
15 to 9 a.m yeah we got up early
your alarms were going off from 8 15 29
a.m yeah give or take yeah yeah about
45. yeah chin how did you not lose your
mind
for us
i get up early
every morning we woke up to three nitro
cold brews from starbucks from chen
which i appreciate it yeah you're
welcome thank you so much good friend
it's the best but what do you think of
our airbnb by the way
the actual airbnb was not bad it's just
the surrounding area wasn't that great
yeah yeah a little yeah a little cd yeah
just like dirty-ish but i mean i wasn't
i didn't feel scared there just it
wasn't it didn't remind me of what san
diego is like sandy was like a beach
city to me yeah yeah
eleven minutes from the club i don't
know how far club we were probably like
20
not too far yeah but not that close
um did you tell him that we saw the one
of the lead guys of american pie dude 30
cover songs kyle invited us today
because you knew the i guess the
bartender yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry she
was cute yeah yeah yeah oh that's a
little shout out but if you're posting
the bartender on your story
that's all she is is your friend she's
100 yeah no no
great friend
yeah for sure yeah hopefully but which
star we're talking jason biggs uh nick
uh what's his name
is kevin from uh what what what's this
oh uh yes
what's the one that's baseball what's
the baseball movie the rookie of the
year yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah rookie you're
just him
[Music]
same guy but when you say kevin from
american pie not not yeah rookie league
of the year very cool yeah same thing
with that guy yeah watched him do 30
cover songs um and he was actually
pretty good yeah his mouth was dirty 30
30.
yeah he's singing smooth criminal he's
really good i would have went up and
broke his arm been like you're welcome
there was a lot of people there there
was
you're welcome if i hadn't heard that
before but that would be you know we'll
go down next time what did you do the
whole time in san diego uh
chin did you jason poon
[Music]
me and brows were basically together the
entire time we actually wrote how crazy
we were we had four songs down within
like the two days they were there we had
actual four songs like written that's
one of them in a top chart
yeah there's some good ones there was a
girl trying to meet you and i feel like
you're kind of oblivious when girls like
want to meet you and stuff there's a
girl in that club and she goes i know
you're from king and sting i go oh
that's cool and she goes i love chin i
go he's right over there
and she was like sticking around and
then she said she checked you she
checked me
and then she did and then she left and i
go chin or she was like over there and i
was like chin this girl wants to meet
you and he goes that's very sweet
and i go i go she knows you from the
show she's like over here he goes that's
very cool and just watch the guy from
america
i was hypnotized man
dude it's kevin it's [ __ ]
rookie of the year bro he's singing
don't stop believing
what's that once in a lifetime
opportunity
any other highlights from san diego
um
i had a good mexican lunch
i did go to the beach uh so that was
nice i've been to the beach since i
moved to california
been out here a year and haven't seen
the beach it's i mean that
never is pretty crazy but i will say
like especially if you live like a
little bit inland on the other side of
the 405 uh you do take it for granted
and it's kind of like a chore to get out
there yeah i don't go as the beach as
much as i would like to that i live here
for the first time in
yeah first time yeah over a year that's
pretty nuts yeah got my feet in the
water it was it was nice i'm pretty
afraid of the ocean i don't know about
you guys
nighttime at night the ocean's scary as
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah
infinite abyss uh what did you eat there
for your last meals oh dude that's a
good segue because i was gonna say it i
did that
i'm saying like perfect timing because i
remember that we got the bacon wrapped
hot dogs
we were like we're order six or whatever
right
freaking fifty four dollars so they're
like eight bucks each now
yeah it's insane
it is they make their own prices i i
uh calculate inflation by the price hot
dogs go up uh i used to like these are
street vendor dogs they're not even
right regular like you know brick and
mortar it's like a cart
crisis yeah or chipotle burritos it was
like that's it's when i was in college
that's literally like okay i'm making
8.75 at this parking lot uh parking ramp
job that's that's like 1.25 burritos per
hour so i just need to
make i don't know like 40 burritos in a
week and then i'm i'm sad that's hustle
right there yeah
uh plus that photographer so you ate you
ate the bacon wrapped hot dogs
this is my last meal before i lose
basically
salty fatty as much as i can get in and
then i ate uh two bowls of noodles when
i got back home on sunday
i said you ate all day so yeah all day
and i had three ice creams i told you
yes yep that worked what's your diet
been nick uh i ate i just post made
every meal this weekend um that's money
dude the aforementioned chipotle
uh i had mcdoub mcdowell's drive-through
which i haven't done in a really long
time what'd you get uh big mac double
quarter powder with cheese the guy
ordered he's really i like to just kind
of play jazz with the fast food menu you
know this
little value menu over here
a little bit chicken double you know
just dance around the guy was like
everything i said he'd be like is that
all is that all i'm like no i'm trying
to [ __ ] i'm exploring yeah ribbon
dancing on your menu and you're [ __ ]
me up i'm glad i'm glad both of you are
taking the weight cut seriously yeah no
because we weigh in today so the move is
i should have been pounding water all
day too i didn't think about that damn
it
that's what the studio buys that's what
happens you leave and now all of a
sudden they're drinking arrowhead
goddamn this place is falling apart now
we had liquid death for a while i think
it's time who's got a uh
camera a mobile camera so we can uh film
chin and i weigh in see how much we
actually um i can go get one
or just even a phone even a phone
anybody who wears a scale i left them in
my other singlet
my other kind
how many do you have i think it's back
there did i set it back there's one yeah
hold on
how much do you think you weigh i gotta
be well you should let us all guess
first oh yeah okay guess i'm gonna go is
it gonna work on carpet though uh
i think scale i think nick because
there's a chance 207. 180
channels 189. how dare you chen's 193. a
little bit
chin's 98 198. that's even better thank
you
is that right i think chin's at 1998
next at 207.
194. try it on the
nick holds it really well but i feel
like
i feel like he's probably 200 i'm saying
he's got to be he's going to be in the
200
201 and almost you're 94 pounds right i
mean i'm 90 pounds yeah i won dude i won
i call them chinorexic
194. yeah 194 for chen
i'm i'm going with my original i said
192. whenever
204. and georgie says i'm 198 right yep
i think your concrete did not help
really so it's off it made me even
lighter on the concrete oh [ __ ]
so we don't understand how many um
pounds is nick's not here
he put money on this i think he's trying
to rig this i just saw him with his
shirt off walking
there he is
oh hold on you got the two socks on it i
think the scale might be a little rigged
you were 199.2 okay 29 to 198 is that
what it was pretty much and he he's
heavier than me which i'm kind of
one person okay
i'm just saying you guys are pretty much
same height same weight yeah yeah do you
have a goal weight you're trying to get
down to i want to get up
less body fat well you're gonna lose
your freaking 600 chin i'm
what do you think you can get down to i
can get down low the date we're gonna
weigh in again is gonna be the first
tuesday after the first
that's like a holiday i think
is it or not no how much is it september
six 199 september six
yep one night nine what okay
that's our weigh-in day it's about six
weeks
my goal i i want to weigh in at the
lightweight limit 196. 190. one night is
my goal okay all right chad
okay that's gambling wait you guys are
both a pound off from each other yeah
it's kind of crazy right i would i would
i thought he was more than me but he i
thought you know you would eat well it
sounds like i would've thought chin was
less than you
why am i not small looking
you're just slender you are slender oh
my gosh nick will look like santa hagan
if he gets down to 156. oh yeah arched
back and all that that i don't know what
he weighs normally but i would say he's
probably in the 150 area um i mean he
fights and i'm 35 you probably when he's
walking around 65. yeah
oh yeah yeah that's what you would look
like speaking of ufc fighters i just got
confirmed that we might be able to have
adrian yeah it's not a confirmation well
no well i'm saying whenever
he's down to do it by definition he's
down to do it it's just whenever you
want to put him on yeah adrian
let's talk to him next time he's her
[ __ ] man brilliant striker his boxing
is so [ __ ] yeah yeah top five boxer
in the ufc oh yeah has to be absolutely
100 um we got other uh fight related
stuff to get to we're like cosplaying
fighters uh doing weight cuts we're
boxing
mma training we do have to spin the
wheel for next week's opponent before at
the end of this episode
we see
george
is his call going to be over because it
add call i don't know
yeah sounds like he's ducking the fight
to me
it seems like that a little bit um yeah
why don't you we spin the wheel
uh should we text justin and see if he's
uh uh uh wants to be on it next week
sure
we tried calling him okay
okay you can uh you could or yeah they
can spin it right there in the middle
between both of them that's a good good
shot
dude
everything's recording right there oh i
just started calling him that's cool
okay
hold it hold it into the like put it
right in the back yeah
and speaker
it's on the speaker
first spin for next week
that's not that's upside down wait is it
that would be no that's there's not a
chin because if it's a c it's a chin
that's a backwards see though
so is that
wait you are definitely backwards no so
if you if you flipped it that's chin
backwards right no watch
it's just upside down yeah chin that's
you
it's not upside down it's backwards no
it's not no because if you turn it like
this it's a c you see no but
i i i i agree with him that it is upside
down the other way because you should
have
wrote it like it with the rotation of
the wheel yeah but uh but if it's me
it's me kyle
yeah
half and half
he probably wrote it upside down because
we haven't taken our magic mind is that
oh that's nick
is that nick
nick and chen
the
well i think that's a z i'm not sure i
don't know is that it we're gonna have
to put full names going forward on the
wheel
uh but chin versus nick it's happened
hell we've been won this last year
this has been in the making longer than
khabib and [ __ ] ferguson it's it's i
do the podcast world's uh floyd
uh logan
yeah 100
i feel like we need to get a map for
that one we got justin uncut calling
right now
is he uncut
such a fan yo jay
yo what up what up how are you
i'm good man i'm good
so chin was supposed to ask you in san
diego to come on the show i don't know
which i did yeah no i no we we we uh
talked about it for a little bit but he
didn't give me the he said either on
tuesdays and thursdays so that's why i
was trying to figure out what see i
thought i thought chin was this is nick
what's going on justin i thought i
thought chin was locking it in he goes
should we have justin on and i was like
yeah let's do it and he was like okay
but then i guess i was supposed to be
yeah so the booker i
we're hamming out the details right
there so blame chin for now no justin i
don't have your number bro i didn't even
know yeah i know we we usually just uh
we me and chandra's usually instagram
messages like that but when i saw him i
was like yeah uh he told me that we
shoot tuesdays and thursdays i said what
time he was like around two or three i
like yeah for sure just let me know and
uh we could definitely
we could definitely lock it in for sure
well we're trying to lock it in right
now or available next tuesday at
three because we have two king and these
things okay
next tuesday at three hold on let me see
oh here we go
check with your agent back to the back
of the rolodex if we get big right now
no you're funny he's all funny y'all
funny as [ __ ] next tuesday is that
that's the second of august right
i don't know is it
i think so i think so we have a yeah we
have a food truck
all right and uh second well we already
spun the wheel would we have to respect
would you want to be on our cats after
dark fight club wheel where we spin and
select two people who have to spar for a
minute at the end of this show
with black
165
man i ain't gonna do that [ __ ] that's
fine okay cool we already spawned and we
got a we got a blockbuster match up so
you just would have ruined it anyways
but we'll see you next tuesday
all right tuesday uh august 2nd all
right i'm putting it in now 3 pm and
everybody check out justin's podcast i
was on an episode with matt daddy
lockwood
hey oh
oh dope dope
what's it called an uncut the podcast
what's it called
oh who's parker justin what's the
podcast called i i wanted to plug i
wanted to plug it i was hoping you would
take the man
right now oh yeah yeah was that not
clear
smoking all right yeah
yeah next week but uh my podcast is
called think before you speak
oh yeah
there you go all right cool we'll see
you next week thank you jay all right
peace out justin
love you
how come justin has never had his
rotation on like fighter in the kit he's
he's on the weekends all the time but
he's not in the podcast ever i don't
know i don't know don't the first time i
ever heard justin get mentioned on
fighter and the kid they made fun of his
plaque and his teeth
after that i don't think they got
mentions a lot yeah he gets mentioned
quite a bit for banging fat ladies i
remember cutting the reel for that one
yeah but i mean to be on fire the kid
that's you know yeah out of my hands you
know what i'm saying
he's uh he's also a shoe plug somehow
yeah yeah he's got swag he has like but
he had something on the other day like
dior shoes with the baiting ape hood
like he gets he's the plug yeah yeah and
he's also a good basketball player too i
played with him before as well oh
speaking of basketball who lost in pig
this weekend
kyle won i beat browse and pig pig what
is pig where are you worse yeah you got
yeah
it'll never happen again it was a fluke
but i did i did nice
yeah good job how did you end up on a
court with a ball did someone bring a
ball we went to a gym
in other words yeah there was a court
there because i i i thought there was
rumblings about getting a basketball
court out in the back here is still i
hope so
i would be okay with it if you guys
if you guys do get one don't go like
you're like trying to be a good dad and
you want to get your kid a hoop and you
get the cheapest hoop that you have to
fill with water or sand right and
they've got the the small circular
plastic back it's like it's a waste of
glass one you don't learn anything get
get yourself a plexiglass backboard six
to seven hundred dollars lifetime in
ground
yep that's the way to do it that's my
tip i used to work at sporty good stores
that's how i'd upsell the parents i'm
like do you care about your child right
i want them to be a winning athlete i
got that for christmas then nobody else
is getting anything for christmas that's
the whole budget
uh speaking of sports i did want to talk
about one thing that's really near and
dear to my heart uh we don't normally
get political on this show but uh this
november on the ballot in california is
props 26 and 27 to legalize sports
gambling
whoa
those native americans are pissed off
it's very interesting uh these
commercials i actually sent christian
one who doesn't seem to be did are you
are you oh he's right in the wheel okay
okay i'm sorry
he's like second you know again i
mentioned i don't have contacts and i
need to get a new prescription i cannot
see
anything at the moment uh oh that's wow
that looks really really nice i can't
like i said they just look like liners
than before okay
uh but yeah so prop 27 it's on the
ballot to legalize sports gambling like
uh george said the native americans are
pissed because they obviously have uh
a lot of casinos yeah we stole their
land gave them casinos to make up for it
now they're printing money but uh if
they legalize a sports game in
california
then
they're like essentially faucet of
income will be run out so they're
running these ant vote no on prop 27 ads
and you're saying the two the two
selling points on vote no are it's going
to hurt the tribes but then the second
part is that it's like addictive and it
ruins a lot of lives but they're selling
it both ways yeah
that
oh we want to keep it legal to so the
tribes but can't that hurt
the people get addicted to it i don't
know here's the uh
here's the propaganda commercial
oh is that on it damn it i sent you the
wrong leg yeah you want to look for uh
vote no on prop 27 commercial well now
we know what you want to do what's funny
is i never had these commercials until
my indian friend came over
and now every time it's literally on
i've never had him until recently that's
because it's election time it has
nothing to do with your native american
friend coming up no he's not a native
american different indian now oh then
it's definitely not the reason you're
talking about loch rana yes i am yeah
that doesn't make sense at all
but uh yeah so it's
i want to be legal i want to be able to
go on draftkings and parlay props we
know
you can't i'm on my book you can't
parlay props you can on draftkings it
ruins everything
sports gambling is essentially like weed
was back in the day it's federally legal
but state by state regulated about half
the states have it legal and they're
kind of dropping like flies but it's all
it's all lobbying and stuff
draftkings and fanduel are actually the
reasons it got federally legal like they
got all these they used all this
advertising to get people signed up for
their accounts back when it was just
like daily fantasy and then they got
billions of dollars in investment to
lobby the government to then make it
federally legal so then they already had
all these customers waiting it was
actually quite genius yeah
they have no product no inventory
i agree yeah yeah
hell yeah
are you ready to fight people thought
you were ducking let's go is this this
guy
it's the same commercial you sign i just
fast forwarded because they just paused
and wrote on it as all
that guy looks like indian jack black
native american is this the real thing
yeah it was like that none of the
writing is on it
in the real commercial
i don't think they were talking about
the bearing straight in the uh original
commercial but i can't find it the point
is native americans want to ruin my life
and not allow me to [ __ ] parlay props
and i want to i want to [ __ ] bet on
draftkings we know we know
even though the next knicks picks
parlays they're gonna make you go broke
uh last weekend was a bloodbath
i mean i feel like yeah what were our
picks last week uh not good yeah what
was what guys do you guys remember this
speaking of sadness they're crying in
you this is the classic native american
commercial the single tier the single
tier
this is what all these uh prop
whatever
prop 27 commercials are reminding me of
where the [ __ ] did barney go he had to
go handle it i'm barney oh it makes you
cry because i can [ __ ] do transformed
evolved you got taller and tanner you
hit a six leg parlay
one tear is gonna roll out of my eye
it's like and where's that editing
careful at getting too tan though all
right
he's not even native american
i want i want i got i got to see the end
i got again yeah we got to see the most
is that a white look at that looks like
that makes me cry too out if i see
someone litter i get so angry
i know i can't litter that's the same
feeling i have my last leg of my parlay
just folds it's like oh i lost all my
money
yeah that's uh really sad there was
something else i wanted to say about
that native american oh i love
there are some commercials like that
that just stick in your mind i don't
know if you can think of one as i as we
pull up mine but this is my favorite
commercial from back in the day
look up geico tiny house
i remember that right against a geico
caveman well i mean that one also sticks
in my mind because they called it
every other gun
message boards
uh but uh i do you guys remember have
any commercials back in the day that
just like i'm trying to think right now
it's it's it's tough to put in the spot
i think about this like every day so it
was easy i remember this one
can you turn it up
jg or the gg
we miss some of the funny parts one time
he hits his head he goes i just want to
make an omelet
[Laughter]
this is kind of awesome
ashley tisdale
no
[Music]
this is not awesome
it's also ahead of his time his tiny
houses are all the rage that is true
but
they're not that kind of tiny house
how long have we been going uh
27 minutes
no way
time does not fly
yeah magic mine thank you james
does anybody else want to inform the
audience i would love to hear someone
else's perspective on what magic mind is
and what it does
and how it's affected or helped your
life
george you've been procrastinating all
the time actually
i've never not procrastinated until i
drank one of these beautiful elixirs
here in front of me magic mine
with uh great ingredients like
ashwagandha and many other mushrooms i
can't remember the name of when you
drink this you just feel revitalized
portabella mushrooms yeah more do more
stress less you heard the song uh bring
it up chin
i'm trying it was good
yeah magic mine i love it thanks james
thanks james of shara the owner of magic
mind
uh yeah this stuff's amazing it'll help
your life uh you're going to see your
to-do great to-do list
oh drink it yeah get lower yeah i just
drink it you need a little bit perfect
it's like it's going to soak in yeah
yeah but you'll start knocking stuff off
your to-do list rather than see it
growing it's anxiety that is what keeps
you from doing those small tasks i mean
this minimizes that yeah because it's so
easy to get overwhelmed i was in a
creative fight big list in front of you
yeah take a little of this knock it out
one by one and then bam you're doing it
christian how can they get magic mind at
a discount if you go to magic mind dot
co slash dark you can get i believe it's
fifteen percent off money twenty percent
why are you serious twenty twenty
percent off
and is there a promo code or does that
take you right to it if you type in
promo code dark then the promo will be
applied and you get twenty percent off
that's amazing and we have these
we wrote ourselves
magic
mind.com
and we've had a number of fans zoom in
it's always a good time and then some
people are like how do i do that i
missed the call we usually put it on the
instagram one way you can do it go to
the front of the line
buy magic mind at magicmind.com use
promo code dark 20 off and then send in
your receipt and we'll talk to you we
want to hear about your experience with
magic mind and uh you can tell us
whatever else you want we don't have to
talk about management the whole time you
can just hang out with us
let's start off do it yeah do it buy the
magic kids we're moving product you have
to drink magic i want to
we're moving some weight for them yeah
two fluid ounces all brian callan
actually though yeah yeah
brian just has mega steak buying all the
products
oh speaking of brian collins maybe we
can add him to the wheel one week
because i know i know he'll keep
everyone he says he'll keep everyone
busy
let's see if he can back up here though
that's the only problem
yeah he's got to show up and listen i've
wrestled with him
he's got some strengths he [ __ ] me up
so strong he [ __ ] me up
but
i don't know father time's coming so
we'll see how much longer you can do
with the video on my instagram of him
teaching me a little bit about striking
you know
pull up that go george go right now
he loves doing that yeah
uh he's a wonderful guy i love brian
when i whenever i'm like down on myself
i just talk to myself in like my brian
callan voice because he's so
inspirational any time you talk to
talk to him he'll just go on this huge
lecture about how you should change your
life for the better and i just interpret
it and repeat it to myself basically
look at this man
teaching the georges a little bit about
it's so crazy how like knowledgeable and
wise he is yet he does not know how to
post an instagram story to save his life
it's insane yeah
he literally called me one day like hey
how do i post a story with a caption and
like brian what do you mean like how do
you not know how to do it he's like
didn't know how to slide over anything
it makes sense though he's like yeah i
tried to collab something with him from
thick boy and it was like
the hardest process of all the time
like two months later we got finally got
it yeah
yeah but the show in san diego
and in arizona and everyone
should we uh
watch some more submissions
hell yeah yeah let's pull up paddy's of
jordan levitt uh that was a good one oh
nice yeah nice double entendre that was
an awesome fight oh yeah that lived up
to the hype uh oh
patty that walkout was sick
[ __ ] the tories
yeah that was
meatball molly mccann
and his speech after it was pretty
inspirational yeah oh yeah that meatball
molly if you ever see this just hit me
up let's go on a date please i love you
wow
should we do a new segment i'd expect
that go on a date with george go george
go
i'd rather be crying my shoulder than be
at his funeral i'm going to say no
already to this guy
why that's [ __ ] up he's the tongue
back don't don't judge a book by its
cover george you put the tongue back
this is uh
teemo on instagram i know just from his
face
talking i'm talking about i know
i'm trying to pause it
but
he
one time theo said he looked like uh
jake paul or fake paul
he didn't happen
the video yeah yeah not here though nick
you were saying that uh we do got a
couple of quick submissions for you just
for you
um yeah very vague little email about
this biggest fan contest you know i had
to call in dude uh love you guys
all day every day and you guys are all i
listen to
from everything from cats after dark to
uh you know a patreon episodes to
youtube and spotify anything i can watch
you guys or listen to i'm on it since
the beginning dude
a huge fan love to be a part of this
thing if i if you guys choose me i
really appreciate it it'd be dream of
mine to see you guys live especially
dude um give your boy shout out gang
gang buzz buzz sword
okay oh yeah i like old blue eyes i like
him he seems like a great guy but i want
people to get like creative yeah yeah
they're submissions it's i mean and at
this point like i feel like we kind of
we i think we should reward the people
that already sent them in with like by
not letting more submissions like so oh
you saw the boring one so you're like
i'm gonna do one to step it up the
people who sent it in i feel like
they're the most enthusiastic but i
agree yeah he just basically pleaded
with us to to have him come which will
get him into the tournament probably i
feel like that's how i got my job here
i thought we all got here
kyle posted that they were you got that
thick boy was looking for help and then
what did you say was it like
i
i don't know i sent some
dm and then he like never opened it so
then i
commented on his most recent picture and
said hey i dm'd you well uh i have a car
and then
that got him
and then
with jordan teemo he's obviously got one
he's here
so george i remember meeting someone at
a ralph's rallies they're saying like
i'm a fan of the show blah blah i
appreciate you uh
no something like and then i he kind of
reminded me of you but it wasn't me
right you've never met me before
i've never met you okay no no no so
whoever that guy is
every time i'm like i'm always thinking
like is that was that george was that
george how long ago was this not it was
before you came before yeah
we just uh got you uh a fight match we
spawned for you you're fighting fake
paul
timo come on come on come on in come on
in here come on boys
so kyle's in chewie's spot today
who's this guy this is dawson from
montana this guy looks like a blue lives
matter manifesto that got stuck in the
nothing wrong
trivia submissions i will just say that
looks like miles teller put on 45 pounds
he's like eric griffith houston montana
i love carson there's no way any of the
fans remember as much or more than me i
definitely got
[Music]
i like that your bones are so thick you
look like you've got rhinoceros bones
can't really hear them
[Music]
i think for just all the submissions and
we'll just do the brackets so you can
like fit them in there will be like uh
like basically buys yeah because we'll
probably have 12 people so maybe do
have a whole bracket yeah yeah are we
gonna have a plan tournament
yeah like the worst four yeah
i will say we got two more and both of
them are very quick and very vague this
was just all that we had for submissions
cool at the end of it so i like it
yeah
sweet straight to the point and
everything so
if this [ __ ] goes over there we go
nick you won't be disappointed man
i know everything there is
oh
[Laughter]
it sounded like about nick's life kind
of like
nick's social security number i think
i've let put most of it on put a podcast
someplace yeah i just love how he sent
this in while he's in front of a
7-eleven slash no no he's out he works
or other places no i think it's i think
it's other places i've never even heard
of it it's like an alcohol smoothie it's
like those iconic like oh
well don't do that
yeah
well this guy knows everything about
[Music]
all right and then
the last one is also a quick one but
this guy just seemed like a nice guy so
you know what
i decided to give him a shot that's why
he's last right no it was just because
it was one of the quickest ones but i
feel like you know this guy i don't but
he just had a nice energy about him
what's up guys got to keep the video
short been on the channel before trying
to get up there again been in catspan
for a long time hit me up and that's
basically that's all the submissions
that we have i like hit us up like a
booty like that he's at a hardware store
i like that that's why he looks like a
hardware guy too it looks like the
hardware store's not finished being
built yet either
it looks like it's possibly like uh i
have a buddy who has like a
pottery uh studio and he's just got
shelves like that that's where he like
puts all his shits down as they drive
that might be his warehouse yeah looks
like a party pottery barn
well not a pottery bar
that's a store
michaels
it looks like a store it has a tags
there
it's also got forensic files boxes up
top for cases all right so how many how
many we have we watched
one two three four five six six let's
find out if that guy was the same four
today ten
yeah we'll just put all ten of them in
and two of them or four of them will
have to be in the first round playing
the game then i'll break it down to
eight then we got to do two yeah i like
championship
dude
and then we fly him out
yeah
if we get him like spirit
even if the guys say no
i don't think they will that's 50 bucks
if you
i mean come on guys i'm just saying
when i came out the king in the sting my
first flight was first class it was wow
we got to cut that yeah don't get there
hope something yeah
so theo doesn't have to yeah he doesn't
hear it no i'm kidding that could stay
in but yeah yeah
well i kind of did that i kind of did
that whole fly george here thing without
talking to anybody
it was my one of my favorite moments on
the show ever
it's a beautiful i walked in and almost
this exact outfit
[ __ ]
um
yeah theo can give away a lot of money
to like felons and yeah
king this thing why can't he fly out of
spirit airlines little blue eyes guys
yeah why can he fly an upstanding
citizen
no we don't like those all right
all right what else do we have
how much boxing experience do you have
i'll tell you after that
he bought march
he boxes a lot i i've assumed so i have
no fighting experience you guys should
agree if you guys wanted to head shots
or just bought it yeah you guys got to
lay down the ground
what do you think um
i'm down for either but maybe
let's start with body and see how it
goes i don't have health insurance
that means you guys are both down for
body shots then right yeah let's do body
shots
you guys won't see high school your
insurance is a workplace injury
[Laughter]
no don't do that
i'm doing the just engaging no surgery
trying to get it broken in the octagon
yeah
it never happens though yeah
all right let's do it all right finish
off the steps
yeah uh i mean the phone works if so
someone can can do it
what's that i feel like a camera would
be the camera would be better if he
wants to go get the camera
cool
give me a second
three three minute rounds should we have
someone put
yeah
i'm not going to tell you what i know
here someone put that on their faces
[Laughter]
bad have you guys not sparred each other
i haven't done any we don't even have
gloves yet uh you have to go four weeks
you have to go one month in to prove it
like half today half the people dropped
out
like when we were actually i don't know
they weren't there when we showed up
half the people were going but why a
month without gloves that just doesn't
make sense
technique you you don't die
you [ __ ] wide you have to watch you
gotta learn you slow
oh for the jiu jitsu and stuff okay i
thought like for the striking that no no
gloves
but that doesn't make sense you need the
gloves for technique you need to get
comfortable with the weight of the
gloves like
four ounces at least oh yeah i'm
thinking possible
because the first time i use 16 training
gloves that's all i like to use yeah
when i i went from 12
i only used 12's i went up to 16 and i
was dead i was like this is you got to
get used to it
brows don't disappoint us
okay well at least you're honest i know
my strengths
rapping is one of them boxing is not if
we play basketball i think i could take
if you hit him in the throat oh you're
killing this
you want to back that up
i just beat you in a pig last year i'll
put whatever on basketball bro let's go
north hollywood courts every morning
let's go every morning yeah every
[ __ ] wow huh how early are you there
like nine eight nine to ten don't you
work
i do i play for an hour with machine gun
kelly's crew and then weird flex uh and
then i go about my day flex
did you say oh machine guy kelly's crew
yeah machine gun
celebrities not because it's them i want
to play basketball
we go early in the morning i oh i can do
that
ladies and
gentlemen we
are
live
from cats after dark
here at the thick boys studios
with
fun
that was great let's fight that are you
ready i don't know well i gotta i gotta
get the timer sorry i was smoking give
us an intro i know
you know okay
last time right
that i'm not taking i'm not taking any
steam away from nick or george they both
did amazing last time so i let i say we
let nick and you're not on the you're
not on a mic i know but i don't want to
do you but you're talking
he's like it wasn't for the mic though
for you
out of the great nation of croatia
he is six foot one
two hundred shut up two hundred pounds
fighting skill
he is
the croatian warrior
george
[Music]
all right get the camera
and his opponent coming out of the great
state of the ohio the state of ohio
he is reigning
defending
100 000 plays on spotify wielding
champion of the world hey it's a million
players by the way
little browns fireboy
austin
and i don't know your last name pollard
oh sorry what is it three one minute
rounds no one just one one that's it
yeah that's why it's not a big deal but
i got super tired when i want to clean
it
nothing below nothing about the
shoulders nothing about the waist plus
was if you want i'm ready to do it let's
get it on
go
jesus oh they're going
damn
oh
that was a heavy shot
oh
brows looks like you're a little nervous
got the street in them george has the
technique imagine
why slipping off the gloves to the
punches to the face
halfway halfway
five continue very strong man
seven very long reach eight
are you ready to go let's go ten seconds
eight seconds
the defense is tightened up get in there
austin
no one wants to fight george all of a
sudden
i'll fight george right now
who's announcing the winner
and your winner
but what did did you was that a knockout
or is he saved by the bell and you're a
winner by decision
[Applause]
oh that was pretty clear
yeah
[Music]
i noticed the more he took the more he
was down the throat yeah he's i think
austin's like street
street
it was a street against technique yeah
he was like a little worried but i saw i
saw in his face a couple times he took a
couple to the body and i saw it switch
yeah and the ohio came out a little foot
came up for a superman punch
isn't it crazy it's one minute but you
get so [ __ ] tired that's why i like
the body's better than the head because
you work the body it takes out more
energy if you get hit in the head like
you can slip and stuff it's hard to slip
my body i don't want to fight yours
i don't know
george is probably like the the number
one guy here for sure there's no
number one contender now like i mean
we've only been doing this a short time
there's nothing i look forward to more
than the spin off the wheel itself like
to see who's gonna i give props to bro
you surprised me you came out harder
than i thought you got some land in some
good shots
yeah i'm surprised you're surprised i
mean he's a athlete but yeah you see but
i know that he only like has a box yeah
so yeah you have boxing experience
besides just the the camp thing yeah
before he got hired to hear he's boxing
like four or five days a week really
yeah
yeah i've been boxing for like two and a
half years when i was in croatia i would
go we like hard spar in croatia like
three times a week against like big
dudes
yeah yeah oh really that's hilarious i'm
sorry
that i keep keeping
i it a guy that knocked him out but it's
kind of hard like bodybuilding doing
body shot like shots only is kind of
almost harder like oh it seems
impossible yeah because then like you
can't target i can't like threaten like
with the jab to the face as much as i
usually i'm so glad we didn't do head
shots
dude do you punch so hard holy [ __ ]
anyone else want to fight him
i mean it's all it depends on the wheel
right it depends on the wheel it's the
wheel did we and
a week off is good i guess i mean it
eliminates two people from the wheel
everything yeah but then also makes the
people who haven't fought yeah we want
to see new fights for sure
i love i love the idea of someone
getting kind of [ __ ] though because
there's just that's what the wheel does
it like the wheel says that could easily
happen to me
like five weeks spree that nick has to
fight all of this
okay actually
that makes me excited yeah it's like um
what's the oklahoma drills or yeah in
football there'd be a one where you like
you're in the center of the circle and
they just call people's name out you
just run and you have to do like 10 in a
row that's that could be the wheel if
if it punishes you
or myself
it's good
chin versus nick though next week i mean
i'm okay so we should agree right now
are we doing
just body shots i think you guys should
do this is what we should do this is
what we should do i'm listening there's
a new
boxing club like down the street we
should like connect with them and
somehow
use their ring get headgear and
everything and do these like legit fight
clubs i got headgear i'm down i i me do
we do one do we do once a month then
yeah and actually do it because it's i
mean that's the thing about like i mean
we're doing it yeah because we'd have to
go we're in and out an hour and a half
and we're just recording a podcast but i
mean that is that maybe we i don't know
it's fine doing this for a while okay
yeah build up we don't need headgear
head headgear doesn't really i don't i
would not do that just keep you from
getting caught
what if before your guys fight me and
christian do a 10 second enter you know
like just a just a quick fight before
you guys go so it's like a tournament
like a car
just just to you know get you know get
you guys excited i would say 30 seconds
yeah you and me yeah
just
fun that'd be yeah
i'm going to lose
a prelim
wait for the wheel
like
wait but you guys are for sure doing it
next week or yeah oh yeah but yeah we
have to agree head shots and body shots
what do you want to do i'm down i'm down
too so but we're like they were they
they were doing like 100 body shots so
we're not gonna go 60 we're not and by
the way when we do this i'm just going
to go off of how hard you're hitting me
then i'll hit you the same
you know same amount of
i'll pop you in the nose once just be
like this is this is
all right it's
on
it's going to be on then what about head
shots for the last 15 seconds we'll say
like hey head shots and then you guys
can see that you guys can do headshots
though you need no i think you need a
mouthpiece like for sure yeah mouthpiece
i agree i say i say we do 50 speed uh 50
percent of uh power fighters discretion
if they want to do head shots they can
do that
so if they're going hard you're going to
go live
i don't think we should go hard i think
we should say yeah i would not go hard
unless i like feel nick trying to knock
me out oh then yeah and i'm gonna go
hard i was gonna say you guys went
higher i got punched in the face yeah i
did actually i don't want to see that
slow-mo oh oh [ __ ] what happened was
defense went up the punch slid off the
glove oh
i saw it happen i called it out i tried
to gotta keep your kitchen talked yeah
it was a good fight it was good it was
fun like my coach edson at mma training
he said you know go hard
yeah practice
you attempted the the accident last week
too couple times yeah oh he's been
it's not just last week he's attempting
that
it's every day even in front of the
coach oh my god really i asked edison i
was like dude does this work in the
favelas i'm like if i just shake him off
my back he's like yeah we're every time
yeah is he jamaican
a little racist but
should we do some plugs get out of here
oh heck yeah
follow me on instagram see payload six
check out the new podcast i'm working on
with keenan thompson it's called you
already know with keenan thompson and
tony marole it's on youtube spotify
apple podcast everything congrats on
that bro that's awesome i guess did
anybody have yeah progress correct david
did anybody have anything else uh
because you
i just assumed the fighting was the end
part but if anybody out anything else
they wanted to hit talk about i do like
talk about the topics there's two little
shout outs i want to give uh we released
on extra thick the first episode of 12
packs with jeff dye
and george that was awesome i did not
know the premise when you guys
said you were doing like the card
opening show i love it you have to drink
a beer before you open a pack it's
brilliant uh how i i haven't watched the
first one how many who how many who
drank how many beers uh i think mike got
to four beers before everyone yeah
so
uh he won the ottawa he's a drunk yeah
he is uh
mike of all people
uh
yeah so um
yeah it's really who gets to the fourth
beer first oh oh i thought it was every
time you open
finish the beer you got to open one yeah
we got every time yes but then when you
get the fourth the first one to get to
the fourth beer gets to open the
autograph yeah the big hit the big one
like we got some fancy guys is it only
capped at four beers or can you do more
maybe as many beers they don't even have
to be beards you can go in there and
drink liquor if you want whoever wants
to come have fun you know let us know
you can open some friggin cards not you
austin sorry that's okay i'll drink red
covering
[ __ ] it yeah there's that and
uh tuesdays through fridays we're doing
mma stick boy fight news on the channel
so please check that out so i don't rip
my hair out doing fight news every day
yeah yeah
um
if you guys want to follow me on
instagram you can nick puts it at the
very bottom of that
and also i mean this will already have
happened by the time but i do just want
to say i have a show
at a like nft convention like a
paid gig at that
convention tomorrow
today's tuesday so i'm interested to see
how that's going to go 10 minutes in
front of a whole bunch of nft people um
that's awesome yeah you're [ __ ]
that's super cool man you're scheisting
from the shyster yeah
i'll uh
[Laughter]
i want to throw some jabs at nfts adam
um so i'll let you guys know how it goes
next time make fun of that guy who like
do you do you ever see the uh i think
you guys did the story he was he lost
like a million dollars worth of board
apes or something and he just tweeted
he's like my apes are gone help
yeah someone like hacked him and then
todd kramer was not i hope he's there
what's up george where's the show at
what time um
tomorrow night so that's july 27th
in silver lake
at 7 30. do you know the venue
cal king studios
or something so people can actually go
i don't know if it's like
i don't know i just got hit up and
they're like hey we have like this nft
mixer
he's like i don't care yeah so i don't
know it's like
i don't know if the patrons bought
tickets beforehand to go to this thing i
don't really know what the deal is i'm
just going to show up and see how it
goes and i just realized the show's not
going to come out yeah yeah
i just wanted to talk about because
that's awesome
and then uh fourth wall cafe august
12th i think i have a show there you go
yeah so you guys can go to that one heck
out my instagram is down below
maybe
maybe
the thing is i copy and paste so it's
not like i'm like i'm like deciding
every week copy and paste don't check it
should we just i had for three weeks
after the live show i did get tickets to
the live show that i did so should we
just not say our instagrams anymore and
just say nick's gonna put him in down
below well
half of us are not in the intro to cats
after dark so it's all right
we do have to change that would love any
uh
yeah put me knocking out brows
i'm kidding
[Laughter]
i may or may not have a bruised rib
right now
but if everything goes as planned i will
be performing in ohio with chin on
august 26th
and you can actually buy tickets to that
ticket link is live so if anyone here in
this is in southern ohio kentucky west
virginia grab tickets come see us live
august 26th friday at the verne rife
center nick we'll put it down below
you guys can also send me the relevant
licks links you'd like and i will add
them as well
yeah okay yeah for sure uh it it helps
if they get sense
you need some help we got you yeah
anybody want to edit uh
another podcast show
just watch that
that's it
so my thing i'm super excited about this
my shirt my collab t-shirt with into the
m this is my camera so dope anything
yeah there it is we worked on this for
like i said two months on my video but
maybe two or three months
still i got it down
about the outdoors
it's available right now nick's gonna
leave the link below hell yeah
underneath all the other links oh yeah
but uh you'll save 10 off automatically
when you click on the link
and uh yeah i'm super proud of it it's
it is it is really cool thanks bro uh
beautiful it's like a snow globe almost
but it's a lantern it's a lantern yeah
and all the stuff that i love yeah
fishing camping are they gonna see their
alcohol here nice
guitars oh yeah you better believe it
yeah content that's how bad my eyes are
it took me that long oh yeah nick
doesn't have his contacts on today right
there okay me and browsers
yeah there it is it's only 24 bucks and
you'll save 10 on the link three for 60.
yeah
it's so cool that they actually put me
on the website too that's so dope
that's awesome so shout out to into the
m and jerome
from international china looks gangster
in every picture he's ever taken i feel
like huh i said you look like a gangster
in every photo you've ever taken oh yeah
thanks dude
seems like that's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said
but i was never in the game
allegedly
you look like every alleged gangster
ever and now i have glasses on dude
there's no way i'm a gangster i'm pretty
sure gangsters don't discriminate
against glasses
[Music]
[Music]
so